david luge herzlich willkommen hier
heute meine sehr verehrten zuschauer
zuallererst episode vorne mit lücke
ich begrüße euch heute recht herzlich zu
einer ersten folge von mobile monday es
mit luca also mit mir und das ist eine
neue serie die unterstützt wird von
google play also danke er darf wieder an
euch an der als steller ihre wir werden
in den nächsten wochen zusammen immer
montags auf einem kanal eine mobile game
spielen und zwar hat man google dafür
extra das neue pixel zugesendet und auf
diesen werden wir heute das spiel ways
to beispielen wie der name schon sagt
geht es mit dem spiel um dumme wege zu
sterben
ganz kurz ein schon von mir eben kurz
aus dem schnitt und zwar geht es bei dem
spiel damals zu deinen nicht nur darum
auf eine lustige art und weise zu
sterben sondern das ganze zeit wirklich
auch in ernsten hintergrund und zwar das
ganze spiel eine sicherheitskampagne der
métro trends in melbourne um unfälle zu
verhindern wir den menschen zu nah am
bahnsteig warten stehen so dass sie
durch den zug durchfahren dazu ge
mitgerissen und zu tode kommen können
also das ganze spieler tatsächlich auch
in sehr ernsten hintergrund das finde
ich einfach an der stelle wichtig auch
noch mal zu sagen das ist wirklich nicht
nur um gegen eine belustigung geht weil
der kleine männchen irgendwie sterben
auf eine witzige art und weise aber ich
würde sagen wir fangen jetzt auch an mit
dem video das hier sind wir und wir
haben bisher keinen anderen weiteren
charakter
die kriegen da allerdings dadurch dass
wir minispiele gewinn von 1 click ich
einfach mal auf play game und wir müssen
jetzt nach links und rechts treppen so
dass wir die dinge hochklettern können
okay ihr seht schon
wir haben ein großer teil uns das auch
es geht schon direkt weiter wir müssen
das hier hier reinpacken und drehen und
dann müssen wir das ja das passiert wenn
wir es nicht geschafft haben es geht auf
jeden fall die ganze zeit voll schnell
weiter und wir müssen hier das ding
jetzt drehen bis auf ist ja das haben
wir geschafft ein leben ist weg wir
gerade sehen ob es da stehe ich jetzt
hast du ja okay wir mit darf ich doch
vordermann islamischen sehen
also auch im wasser sind wir leider
gestorben
connect the whales okay wir müssen die
beiden verbinden und die beiden das
haben wir hingekriegt das heißt die
person kann licht anmachen bei sich
einem immer noch ein leben im dreck okay
wir müssen ihnen hier drauf packen okay
noch mal und noch mal
ok erst im krankenwagen immer noch ein
leben am start freude das heißt sie
waren direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
spiel als krude scratch okay wir müssen
ganz schnell drehen damit wir den reiter
das ist ja wie stellen muss man das ding
drehen als sie merkt schon dass geht bei
dem spiel um geschwindigkeit und dann
bin ich nicht so gut aber kommen wir
probieren sie einfach noch mal wir haben
nun allerdings mit unseren glorreichen
leistungen vorhinein zweiten charakter
freigeschaltet der aussieht wie eine
mandarine mache jetzt auf jeden fall das
nächste spiel hier muss sich gedrückt
halten genau immer wenn wir beide male
kurz sind also das haben jetzt glaube
ich geschafft genau als er hat überlebt
und steht jetzt im staub das ist blöd
allerdings geht es direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten minispielen tab to jump mal
wieder also wir müssen ja auf die
nilpferde drauf springen so 12345 ich
höre ich diesmal rasiere ich flieg mit
seinen komischen luftballons auf
jedenfalls auf die andere seite rüber
und ist angekommen also 203 punkte habe
ich 233 sogar im connect aways wieder
also hier so also sind auch teilweise
die gleichen minigames bin ich auf jeden
fall sogar das spiel
ich hab's geschafft mein gott ich habe
immer noch drei lebenden summarum also
die die noch nicht abgelaufen ist und
hab ich alltag ich habe immer noch alle
drei leben aber es geht direkt weiter an
wir haben hier das ding und ich glaube
da muss es einfach essen
[Musik]
ich habe immer noch alle drei leben
das nicht den typen auffangen das
minispiel hatten wir auch vorhin schon
dh jetzt beim dritten mal fliegt er dann
nach ganz rechts oder beim vierten mal
jetzt genau sagt da fliegt darüber in
den krankenwagen und wird
dementsprechend gerettet als ich sehe
dies war wirklich gute chance dass wir
das schaffen wollte baseball caps ich
bin total ebenbeck aber ich habe keine
ahnung was er machen muss
wir haben wir diesmal zwei bären und er
kriegt auf dem kopf und jetzt werden wir
hey ich habe doch gar nicht gedrückt
wollte baseball betz und ich hab's ich
hab's mir nicht ich bin zweimal ist die
gleiche scheiße jetzt gestorben
das aber in 776 guter score
mal gucken ob wir eine neue person
freigeschaltet haben ja wir haben er
steigt jetzt hier aus dem zug aus er
sieht auf jeden fall auch ziemlich
eigenartig ausmachen allerdings direkt
weiter und zwar wieder mit den westen
da habe ich die beiden getötet dafür
bekommen wir 130 punkte dreck don't let
ach so ich dir die ganze zeit nach links
und rechts damit der perfekt gut spüren
kann man kennt ich hab' ich hab leben
verloren und war
was ist das jetzt big ben was muss ich
machen was muss ich machen ernst seien
falsch gelandet so alles gut
okay das war nicht so gut ich habe keine
ahnung was ich gerade machen sollte ich
habe keine ahnung was jetzt gerade was
hier er wird vom zug überfahren
es geht so schnell dieses spiel
man kann nicht mal zwinkern kurz und es
ist eltern hat schon verloren ganz kurz
vor euch übrigens auch eben die info
warum ich hier so übel sexy aussehe
ich hab mir gedacht habe jetzt ja diese
neue serie auf meinem kanal haben namen
kann man ja immer noch das beste aller
zeiten ich habe mir gedacht dass hier
wird einfach die mobile monday brille
aber er komme ich will es jetzt nochmal
wissen
jetzt steht auch mal mein gott ich muss
es neigen damit er nicht ich habe - 93
zählt auch hier wieder take your day das
ist doch die solche aber ich muss landen
ok gelandet bin ich auf jeden fall wir
sind ein pick up store und er hat seinen
essen abgeholt klar wer kennt nicht wenn
pilot hunger hat einfach kurz zum pkw
geht es wieder um westen dich töten muss
und ich glaube es ist wirklich bei dem
spiel sodass man von mini game zu mini
game weniger zeit hat deswegen steht
auch fest
tepco rief you keep berger ich keine
ahnung was macht musste ich bin
er führte er ist tot
und ich hab verloren wenig so scheiße in
diesem spiel
hier musste ich wieder das handy in die
richtung der ja bitte hey ich habs doch
geneigt das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein dies treibe es träumt okay ich kann
hier draufklicken dann kann ich teile
zerstören das im weltraum habe ich auf
jeden fall überlebt und er jesus
minispiel hatten wir auch schon und zwar
muss das handy wieder halten dass er
vernünftig landet das haben wir diesmal
auch wieder mit bravour hingekriegt das
heißt der typ hält auch wieder in seinem
pick up store 90 natürlich seinen essen
ab 242 punkten mittlerweile fest da
steht hier der typ springt er wieder
raus das ist das einfachste minigame von
allen auf jeden fall der typ geht jetzt
auf jeden fall wieder in seinen
krankenwagen überlebt dementsprechend
wir haben jetzt allerdings 300 282
punkte hätte portugals ok ich muss die
streicheln aber auf jeden fall auf das
mini spiel geschafft mt job.de ja ich
konnte nicht mal lesen
was da steht haye tepco titel gab es
geht es gibt so dass das könnte
natürlich auch sonst klick wieder auf
play gerne er das kann doch nicht wahr
sein ich muss das doch irgendwie mal ein
bisschen besser hinkriegen soll die
beiden was hab ich verbunden der typ hat
strom das heißt wir kriegen davon schon
mal punkte schreibt ihr wollt pilgerns
okay also ich muß zweiten und darüber
genau jetzt hier über jetzt hier rüber
ich werde verfolgt verlegen durchaus
möglich war einen müllsack und musste in
den müllwagen aber okay wir machen
weiter mit meinem lieblings minigame
hier das habe ich bisher noch kein mal
verkackt weiter hier so rüber genau der
wird darüber geschleudert wieder in
seinen wagen rein
diesmal schafft except uhr wollte ok ich
muss da ernst hier muss ich wieder töten
damit der astronaut drüber geht zu
seinem helm er die wünschen
einfallsreich was die ganzen games
angeht hier geht wieder um den bären der
da sein komisches kläger ich hab es dass
das ist fake news sg wiederum fester m
und ich muss die die ich muss jetzt hier
drehen und gehen ihr auch dahin um den
auch und dem wieder zurück und so hahaha
okay dass das nächste es geht wieder um
die west modus ist sauschnell okay aber
ich habe das auch das geschafft
ok luca konzentrier dich weiter geht's
fenster entweder westen ob ich okay und
ist jetzt wieder ich hab's wieder
geschafft alter man kann hier wirklich
gerade stolz auf mich sein okay es geht
wieder um zählten das okay auch das
hamburg
wir sind bei über 900 punkten connect
once okay ganz schnell das war auch easy
jet über strom
wir müssten jetzt bei über 1000 punkten
sein das ist krass ok fässer der typ
wieder mit seinem piloten ich werde sie
links rechts links okay jetzt wieder
nach rechts rüber jetzt wieder nach
links okay das läuft das läuft das läuft
wieder hierüber das paar das in einem
bauwagen ich rasiere gerade es geht
wieder an hier um ok das ding ist
kleiner geworden das ist ein bisschen
blöd aber ich glaube auch dass nun dahin
genau und so luca lastet zeigt dass die
zeit wir haben und jetzt hier zu anderen
perfekt hey ich hab gerade echten lauf
1255 punkt haben wir auf jeden fall die
person ist in der waschmaschine wir
müssen das ding drehen und das ist
gerade so schwierig was ist los mit dir
boston ab die haben 1400 okay
aber ich habe 1396 pumpte das
ist ein neuer weltrekord anders wenn ich
das heute wirklich sauber hätten meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die heutige
erste episode wieso zeige ich eine zwei
wenn euch der erste teil hiervon mobile
man jetzt sogar gefallen hat dass
umgehend einen daumen hoch oder dem
video hier da und schreibt mir gerne in
die kommentare was euer high score bei
diesem spiel ist vielleicht habt ihr das
ja selber und falls nicht findet ihr auf
jeden fall noch einen link unten in der
infobox
wo ihr euch das spiel runterladen könnt
im google places ist auf jeden fall
megageil also ich feiere das spiel
obwohl es mich auch ein bisschen
aggressiv macht wir befinden uns hier
nun allerdings auch in der end karte ist
heutigen videos und wenn ihr hier rechts
auf das icon von bamboo es zwei drei
klicks irland direkt in den google
places und könnt euch das spiel was ich
heute gespielt habe runterladen und dann
könnte ich mir auch mal gerne hier und
in die kommentare schreiben
ob ihr einen besseren score da ein
schlechteres creutzig erzählt habt noch
mal danke auf jeden fall an der stelle
google players sie das heutige video
unterstützt haben und wir sehen uns in
einer woche wieder in der zweiten
episode